we interrupt this program to stupid dog
you made me look bad my name is Benoit
and welcome to so well welcome welcome
you are it's good to see it it's been a
great week hope you boys had a great
week as well if you're new basically
Friday victory by Friday prepare it's my
weekly shaking with your birds to see
that everything is that you know I don't
know but yeah I hope your brothers had a
great week
I had especially fun with my keyboard if
you know what every no no I'm not doing
that it's that bad I've been playing
them weird games lately like we kick
game but sounds fun you bro seems to
like that kind of stuff anyway I know
there's like a ton of people who's like
you got to play Minecraft but I I don't
know I like to play games that aren't
like to play but it seems like yeah
horror games is becoming more of the
thing now on YouTube that but it was fun
to be original for a while I have it's
also been an insane how much support you
must have been showing lately some
amazing fan art I want to show it to you
I'll do a little slide while
talk about staff um I really appreciate
all the fat I can't believe I can get
getting so much still it's crazy crazy I
guess it's just fun to draw me every
there was also ton of awesome cosplay
like constantly of me what that's the
father was in it Tara pretty car good
yeah it's been a awesome to see that you
both show it still shows so much support
I get so many message on a daily basis
it's like hundreds of them I could
literally sit down and answer messages
24/7 and I would still not answer all of
them so even though like bro army is
growing which is awesome
yeah I'm still just one guy I'm still
one person so I hope you understand if I
I can't answer all the messages I
basically had this idea that I would
send a little card it's it's nothing
really it's too stupid I'll sign it and
it will be just like a thank you for
your support or something like that I
don't know you both do so much for me I
just feel so ungrateful sometimes I
thought I would be a good idea let me
know in the comments if you think so as
well
but yeah finally if you remember last
week I had like a music competition and
the submissions were awesome I couldn't
decide on which one I I prefer to let
you bros vote and it was so close with
only 50 votes between the winner is can
I get a drumroll can I get a drumroll
it is thank you
now d-day mhm pretty epic job bro
congratulations
[Music]
it was so close to little VI hope is not
like god dammit I didn't when he didn't
seem like that type of guy anyway so I'm
sure he's cool about it and still still
was awesome to see thanks for all the
submissions that were all really epic
I'll definitely do more of these also DG
alpha so it was also really close there
like I forgot to mention but yeah I'm
actually gonna announce another
competition right away not a
complication here but but I know you
like winning stuff so if you're like a
developer of mods and games and stuff
like that you might be interested of
this it's basically me and Rumple the
maker of cry of fear we're doing a
competition together where you create
your own custom story and we'll be
judging it from scare whatever design
and stuff like that so if you're
interesting that check out the
description for more rules and stuff we
have some awesome prizes we actually got
it sponsored by me on NYX which is like
a gaming company so you can basically
win gaming stuff from them so definitely
check that out if you're into that kind
of stuff so yeah Rumple made a video
explaining the rules and all you need to
know about the competition so check that
in description if you want to see more
of that but yeah yeah I think that was
pretty much all I had to say today I've
been doing some more livestream lately
so be sure to follow me on Facebook and
Twitter in that kind of time I hate
saying that it sounds so stupid follow
me and page back I pose really
interesting stuff no but seriously it's
I like to do like short quick and
livestream every once in a while and you
bro seem to enjoy themself but anyway I
have to wrap this up thank you both for
all this apart you know it's coming I'm
gonna punish you tonight I'm recording
here to hell
what the girlfriend is drunk as always
but anyway here comes the brothers stay
awesome rest
[Music]